combing through sand on the beach you
can discover rich clues to the natural
world likely your findings won't be
monumental maybe a few shark teeth or
shells that's unless you're in a region
known as the Xan motor or sand engine on
the coast of the Netherlands one
particularly prolific beach Comber Willy
vanwyngarden has uncovered more than 500
relics from the area that tell the story
of ancient humans and how they lived in
a vanished landscape vanwyngarden
recently brought one of her finds to
researchers they concluded that the
birched are smeared at the end of the
tool was evidence that Neanderthals
could produce complex tools that took
several days to make these discoveries
all became possible in 2012 when
material dredged from the bottom of the
North Sea was dumped on the beach to
create a buffer against sea-level rise
but the dredged area hasn't always been
covered by water until the end of the
last ice age sea level was 70 metres
lower exposing a hundred eighty thousand
square kilometres of land an area known
as doggerland ancient humans likely
traversed doggerland for hundreds of
thousands of years researchers have long
suspected this underwater area to be
rife with clues to the past in the past
few decades fishermen of the north sea
have netted fascinating finds like the
tusks and skulls of woolly mammoths and
woolly rhinoceros and as dredging an
excavation have ramped up more artifacts
have seen the light of day these
artifacts on the beach or found from
other dredge piles are usually
well-preserved enough to date and
researchers can confine their origin to
the few square kilometre area where they
were dredged from researchers have
started a systematic survey to unearth
the history of doggerland using clues
from dredging sites and technological
advances in mapping submerged landscapes
using seismic surveys researchers can
understand the underwater topography of
the North Sea this helps pinpoint likely
areas in the landscape that ancient
people traversed
the first site discovered using this
technique was by Europe's lost frontier
the mouth of a prehistoric river found
near the brown banks an area 50
kilometers off the UK coast a large
Flint core axe was recovered from this
location and there could be other finds
to come sediment cores extracted from
these promising areas can yield
artifacts and fossils and millions of
DNA fragments by comparing the DNA
fragments extracted from cores around
the prehistoric Rhine River
- already known genomes researchers have
identified traces of a variety of
animals bears birds boars
and plants like hazel and meadow grasses
that lived in doggerland in years past
these fauna and flora show that parts of
doggerland were lush and fertile
conditions ideal for humans while the
DNA of sea grasses and fish in the core
show the transition to an ester in and
marine environment these transitions can
give greater detail about the history of
sea level rise in the area it could even
tell us how modern civilizations have
responded to similar changes
beachcombers have discovered many
well-preserved human skeletal fragments
and of the teeth and bones tested
several have shown evidence of DNA these
new samples can help provide a more
complete history of Europeans genetic
paths as surveys and cores increase in
number researchers hope to not only
better understand doggerland
but use these same techniques to
understand other submerged landscapes
around the world
for example researchers think that
traces of the very first Americans lie
beneath the ocean off their western
shores of North America doggerland is
just one underwater site teeming with
ancient history and with these new
methods in hand we may just know where
to look for more
[Music]